I always write to music and as I was
writing before yet I kept hearing to any
Elfman meets Jesus meets gospel which
sounds really weird labyrinths like the
first person is like yeah I felt like I
knew exactly what he wanted to go for
the wonderful thing about lab is he
works from just pure inspiration most
school writers they have a very
traditional way of writing they've gone
to school so they use a certain sound
and for me I feel like before we are
told me what to do
whatever makes me feel excited I'm gonna
find a way of injecting it into the
music for me with every scene it was
just like how can i elevate it but do it
in a modern but fresh way labyrinth
would bring out certain hues in the show
I wanted to merge different genres and a
lot of my music has influences of
classic seventies rock but also has
orchestral arrangements along with
hip-hop I kind of have two styles
maybe my angel and my devil side
I'm a very spontaneous creative one day
I want to make a house record the next
day I want to make a classical record
the next day I want to make an
electronic record I'm not a precious
person when I write music I'm like let's
all get involved together every
collaboration helps develop my music
there's nothing we love more than but
just sit there and cut laps music and
just play around with it
we'll play it backwards we'll strip it
up and just try different things so it
becomes this was good sort of you know
back and forth it's a very very unique
relationship with a composer that's uh I
don't led to I think a very
one-of-a-kind texture whatever the
school needed I would adjust my style
euphoria gave me the freedom to be
whatever artist I want to be there's
this kind of hopefulness to his music
that feels triumphant and serves as kind
of a North Star for the series itself
labyrinth score was just better than I
could ever dream up
[Music]
you